nice wave
video in you now before i transplant i
was really breathless
i was passing out in the midst of the
pandemic her life was transformed
i can think about the things i always
wanted to do in the future
fourteen-year-old freya had a world
first organ transplant
among just six british children who've
received a dead heart
brought back to life i feel so lucky
i'm just blessed to be able to give the
second chance at life and
to know that i have a future like my
friends and
family do this is the pioneering machine
previously only used to transplant
hearts into adults
once someone is deceased
ideally we want to
bring the patient into theater open the
chest
retrieve the heart uh
connect the heart to the uh to the
transmedics to those yes the heart in
the box
uh everything in less than 30 minutes
because based on our experience so
everything all these steps
uh which have to be performed very
quickly by the same time
very accurately because if we rush too
much
we might be in danger of damaging one
organ or another
it works by keeping the heart inside a
chamber at 34 degrees celsius
plugged in with a plastic connector and
kept beating by pumping one and a half
liters of oxygenated blood
in through the aorta a flowing cycle
with the heart rate itself sped up using
a remote control
it was literally like holding your
breath usually the children's heart
transplant waiting list is up to two
years
and what freya's parents were expecting
on the back of my mind it was a worst
case scenario
you know is that's our last christmas
with her or do we have one more
christmas left
that was the reality that was the
reality of it
instead they got the call within eight
weeks
months later freya was living a normal
life
all delivered during a global pandemic
it
just gives everyone hope you know and it
gives parents hope
it means more organs can be used with
less time waiting and for more
children it means simply the gift of
life
things that people take for granted i
don't anymore
adele robinson sky news bristol